[Musik]
hallo ihre person bleibt einem reinen
angst wahlkampf gute idee
problem bei dem was experten realität
nennen
die zahl der straftaten in deutschland
pro 100000 einwohner seit 1993 leider
gesunken
langweilig wir lassen uns nicht von
fakten mit wahlkampf versuchen wir
abwehr geriet ich verbreite für ihre
partei als allgemeines klima der an
ob im park oder auf dem wagen flug
endlich schluss mit langweiligen
kampagnen über gerechtigkeit und schon
gewöhnt buchen sie mich so plakate wie
pdf damit der hier draußen bleiben
fragen ihrer fans die weg gegeben wenn
ich tagelang mit einem fernseher durch
hierfür glaube
hans kaufmann weil ihr abdel karim
jugendlich war auch kindergeburtstage
[Applaus]